this video is sponsored by one of my personal
favorite Services rocket money more on them
after the reaction [Music] people citizens of
the reject Nation we are back the trio is back
for Echo episode one today ladies and gentlemen
if you're watching this video maybe you already
watched all five what did you think about the
series John how are you I'm excited cited cited
Co he took my joke joke joke joke I was going to
do the same same same same same I can't see that's
the other one rule of Threes baby leave a like
on this video ladies and gentlemen also be sure
to subscribe click the notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next episode
is up cuz we of course going to cover the whole
series thank you to prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights and a massive thank you
to all who have joined us at our patreon page
becoming super sexy rejects over there we do
full in action watch alongs where you sync up
with your own copy of said movie or show we also
covered several things exclusive with highlights
from watch alongs included with this being the
first episode though of the series it is made
public for everyone Link in the description box if
you wish to do a watch along let's get into action
[Music] Pap that's exciting for
a Marvel show we'll see challenge
accepted oh sweet hey it's like the Kori T
pool like I thought might relate and everyone
was like Co it's different world and I
was like I think multiversal will play
here wow look so
Cosmic
cool oh wa this is mature yeah bodies
silhouette damn that's beautiful
it's like [Music] annihilation
people of the hollow
Earth that's cool so this is why she
was able to defeat Hawkeye yes all of
this damn it what kind of bird is that
symbolism
oo oh damn just a bunch of colonizers rolling in
above them yes that was just a giant flag being
planted o oh that's neat that's some cool makeup
that's a really cool effect shedding the clay of
the earth almost like being dusted but not ah
yeah whoa and we all have clothes the first
ch's name was cha she saved her family from
their game Cool are they completely redoing
her origin that's the story of the first shot
people cool oh imagine yourself through there
no we're cousins no Exposition ran straight into
the uh Red River [Laughter]
barash oh that the oh dad's
back I think you're Peaches I don't know what the
actresses but these two actors I know and they're
great yeah I remember thinking the casting for
this was stacked it'll be better in a few days
oh what are you feel like I'm missing
something at this bird you Quail scrub
J then why are you here I I don't know my
birds guys my research M of Theon Society
it's not a black cap Chickity it's the
only one I know cuz it was on a clock I had
once a no don't go in the storm that's where
things happen horrible things something eating
you I don't know ancestors whispering in
your ear again goddamn ancestors why don't
you asking for something good like a bar
ball the ancestors are always playing the
scratchers oh
no jeez
chiste that's the teest bone to ever
T-Bone so far I am appreciating how dark
and dtic this is and oh my god
oh that's how she lost her leg
[Music] Yeah a that's sad damn
who did this score to this
appreciate how cinematic it is the actual Musical
music itself yeah it's more emotional than just
like superhero score I found out who cut the
brakes they're taken care of no who you think
that makes me feel better that another family is
now destroyed makes me feel better wow I told her
those Lopez boys are no good thugs criminals
no nuh-uh you took her from us you all right
I think it's time to go no it's time for him to
go before someone else gets hurt before someone
buys a tracksuit Henry got me a job where New
York isn't that far enough no wow leave the
country interesting how it started off like so
mystical and Fantastical then it's become this
like more and more grounded focused family
drama and watching the grievance around the
supporting characters and not really so much
on Maya yet yeah her origin would have to O
to it's actually a copyrighted
[Music]
image no that you did
not nah man can't imagine having
to tell a kid that no it's not not
a big deal yeah Sunday I I do it as a
side drob hobby breaking tough news to
miners she's a veteran too no they
got a lot of actors who are great
with solely expression of Sorrow
Through The Eyes I go too [Music]
[Music] a man they shot all this
on the volume huh y oh it's New
York wait isn't C Hawkeye yeah
it's like a flashback call ask
your uncle Danny Rand maybe they are but
dragons live in a different world yeah sh
chos be season 3 that would make them stronger
you have to learn to jump between two rooms like
kahori watch interesting how having this
scene in Hawkeye makes you think of it's
a completely different kind of context
yeah and he's in a track suit for someone
surviving as someone who is uh hearing this
is the Kingpin intro school is your focus
you're going to grow up have a different
life but then having the mystical opening
makes it a completely different context yeah
that three minutes very different tone of
show uhoh hey bro at the dojo come
on not at the Mojo Dojo Casa house
it's a sacred place the Mojo
Dojo Casa house may episode
one ready jeez that look great edit love
that is this exactly what happened in
Hawkeye I wased in Hawkeye that one time
but I believe this is 100% the same thing
[Music]
but as a fan of certain animes I like going back
to scenes like letting the flashbacks really play
out again because like an expanded mythology you
got to taste and then it well yeah just like the
recontextualization of just seeing it like this
versus the first time you watch it yeah we're
so H lighter yeah you view it in a completely
different lens even though you're watching the
same exact scenes it gives it further Dimension
but it does does make it the shared Universe
feel richer to have Ronin and the pilot and
to like expand what we do know of [Music] her
ooh
Daddy
[Music]
O I still love that marking to get the David
maart like the the style of the yeah the bloody
handprint oh there's still sister cousins
where's Daredevil he's doing a walk of
shame as I watch She-Hulk I want to see
Daredevil when I watch Ekko I want to see
turle a here we
go the [__] how's she going to get out
of this she's going to do some Taskmaster
[__] that's really cool I love the sound
design TR damn that was actually a really
cool action visual what's the point of that Maya
you're still trapped just a big big F you just
want to make a point if I can't have this shiny
red bike no one C oh look at that music [Music]
CU beat these guys head in the
door I like how the cops are just terrified and
back away we all mourn your father I understand
your age my father was killed also a real piece
of work when I was 12 years old Netflix is Canon
let me help help you release this rage in a
more constructive way let me take you to a
rage room ad job you have greatness in you it is
cool to see Vincent back always your loss take
your pain make it into something useful this
is way more the Kingpin I wanted back but you
know V Kingpin is pretty cool too Trader Joe's
Kingpin baby yeah restrain Kingpin is always
more terrifying than just flailing you want
it to like build and that was a great scene of
him yeah whatever I love how New York
suddenly feels like kingpin's always
been here yeah that's how it should really
like should be in the shadows it's entire
yeah and that's what the Daredevil show
should be yeah we got some more out of the
camera you're clear up uh oh uh oh
what's this guy gonna do where they
going to see she gonna have to like lay this dude
out make those dudes turn around yep yep
yep she's cool so many channels now have
YouTube videos they can make when standing
up for themselves and things that they
definitely go through in a day-to-day
scenario but it's woke they're trying to move
in on FIS territories we're going to take them
out let's try something else she'd be so much
prettier if she smiled more oh I agree Oh you
mean that sarcastically yeah wait wait wait who
should I agree with I do find it interesting that
no one's prepared for her deafness even though
kingpin's like a father Uncle figure Kingpin
thanks you for your loyal he's got people he's
busy who Jesu christe oh it's a Warner will it
be in a hallway is this a hallway get Dar EP
I think we would get dared I me based on the
timeline it would make sense like a daredevil
right now I got two more for the meeting what
no no it's cool bro they're expecting us
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cool damn oh hell
yeah
got his coffee oh oh that was
sick the gunshots man great camera
work Maya do something oh yeah this is very
violent I like it a lot damn nice I love that
she gets brought in through a POV shot and
a perfect time for a hidden cut the way they
choose to go in and out of her perspective via
audio design is really interesting and there's
a slight push every time right when it clicks
over oh yeah there was a crun oh cool cool there
was a CR I like that focusing on the heartbeat to
get the emotionality and the calming back down ex
exertion that's right Maya G
that AES is always red that was
awesome yes death usage
just hey you [Music] again oh damn are
they using wires or did he just jumped that
nice that was [Applause] [Music]
legitimate here we go here we go
here we go oh no yo dude right yo damn it
no you guys could be a couple oh I love
the suit I've been watching them
all night and then you guys show
up I screwed everything up oh this feels like
daril oh God a those blocks and stuff
great o the T great hold on the [Music] kick
oo oh great seamless cut this is excellent
camera use the chain link fence I think is
also choice no Maya go back to she Jesus no
guns The Matrix Arenal yeah very much more
John wicking he is moving so well excellent
stunt work and they keep pulling in
on her one foot too aw they cut it
yeah he's way faster than that none of my men
have ever held their own with him like that
you did better than even I expected it's like
throwing Echo into the Daredevil K immediately
yeah what you lacked was a place and a purpose you
have that now with me oh in my black suit we're
family no matter what thank you Uncle a this feels
so much more Netflix than the Disney Plus show how
so Hawkeye Stu Hawkeye stuff I've dedicated all
my resources into bringing your father's killer to
Justice this feels like a Luke ban movie when you
find him he's mine I wouldn't have it any other
way Clint you count and I were the
same don't put Jeremy rener in the
snow it's okay he's back acting now
it could be used be manipulated your
boss wanted your father dead yes
your boss you're lying wasn't a
typhoon TJ's
Kingpin it's interesting seeing
these visuals from Hawkeye which
felt a little bit in conflict with
the actual show itself but they here
because they were the Netflix scenes in
the plus and now this is the show what a
surprise yeah like they play more Sinister
and menacing even though they're the same
scenes yeah father family wonder if they change
the sound design too on these be interesting to
compare oh yeah definitely finished the
job because of the splicing there is some weird
Pace I'm enjoying it it's a very doing a lot fast
but but it's pastes a little funny but one episod
I am really enjoyed it there's enough working for
me here though I think it's really singing pretty
high I feel like the show's starting now but it's
a very it has a very luk based sound vibe to me I
thought it was going to be more flashback spread
throughout the season I expected like Daredevil
episode two and to jump around they're really
covering their bases where's your suture or that
or that works Terminator is going to appear your
clothes and your boots I need them there's
a 53 on that truck there is that an Easter
egg I was thinking of every issue that I really
do I couldn't think of was all the blood on the
motorcycle going home to see family oh that
was a super clean cut I love that cut good
match so far this has shot so uniquely do
not fall asleep on your bike oh there's a
also incredible in camera stunt work
top to bottom like has there been any
I other than the very
[Music] beginning just need to go play for a
little while don't we all yeah so busy with
the grind you forgotten how to play and
have fun the grind being murder murder
crime how can you floss if you can't hear
what do you listen to your teeth got I hear
him that I heard that was a crunchy
[Music] yeah feels alien little bit feels
like Prometheus with the engineers yeah I
care more about her in the last 40
minutes minutes than I did in the
whole Hawkeye show they've done a really
good job reestablishing it's weird because
I care more about Hawkeye in the last
40 minutes and met Murdoch of course
but I mean it might just be the people who live
here whose home you no don't shoot cousin no
there still might be if my
grandma finds out so much
squatting here there's going to be hell to pay
Maya it's me biscuits biscuits hey that's
Billy Jack nice name he looks like a Billy
Jack I've never been to Oklahoma
but these feel like people not
from California and I really like
it they're so calm they don't feel
like actors I wish I knew you were coming
for for a conference and and some in and
out but what if Grandma sees you sleeping on the
couch it's a ghost immediately like this guy well
cast he's got secret fighting skills he's got
John Vibes my is [Music] back everybody needs a
foggy Nelson and they got a good one iron rings
yes black crow there's so many names I'm trying
to catch D there's a lot of really cool like
Center framing symmetry they do with a lot of
these shots and some cool Focus lenses I wonder
if this is a real town or B or you know like a
place with a real level of indigenous Heritage
it's the volume it's all the volume these people
are the volume oh yeah those are those AI
extras they keep telling me about where's
Daredevil he's in the AM sneak pre the next five
episodes go pop out Bonnie B Bonnie Bonnie yeah
Skate life Dam there are so many tracks so many
music tracks oh my God I need a Saturn's ring
disco ball make a mar skate again oh it's not
Kyle gner he should get in the Marvel Universe
he should I have a headache it's that guy he's
on agen of Shield you ain't from here but you
look familiar how come mystery is your thing is
it guy's a combination with Evan Peters and Boyd
Holbrook yeah oh great call Evan holbrook's doing
good work this dude's a good actor so it going to
be well if you ain't here to skate he ain't
available 7 bucks to skate or it's five bucks
to watch or you go ahead and spend that $5 on a
Butterfinger blizzard five bucks to watch Voyer
skate Evan Holbrook is really good at playing
like detached sociopathic characters so I'm
curious as to who this guy turns out to be yeah
I worry for his safety [Music] inevitably we knew
we couldn't trust you Evan Holbrook damn you dude
the king killer king killer this information made
it all the way to Oklahoma probably because
they were like criminal underbelly really it
reached didn't it like that that team of people
oh yeah yeah yeah I mean her her papy had [__]
going on out here took it out there so he's all
right the pain in my ass but he's worked for me
a painus in the anus so they finally caught up to
you oh it's like her dad's to two bullet or blade
all right are we working with here what a cut
I'm a big fan of the transition keeps the Cana
from slipping out of your karate during the
sanguin but uh I don't think we're bombing you
today always a good
[Laughter] day a full this guy moves I
like the accent of his speech with like
I love how he talks oh T nice
take a deep breath that looks
infected uhoh she's safe is she with
this telescope up here if she finds
out you were here and you didn't see her you will
break her heart your sisters yeah
there is a firmness in the way he
talks Fisk that's an Easter egg that's why they
know yes but but to what what does that mean Feast
Fe oh they spelled fist wrong all right we got
to explain the ending video coming up I figured
you needed more for me than stitches here's
10 guns how far is Oklahoma from New [Music]
York I won't bring a war here to the
people I love oh why are you doing
this uhhuh oh green pitten crime Mommy does she
become the queen of crime no I mean
she ends up bring a daredevil quite a
bit dude man her drips too that fishnet Le
jacket combo no there there's an element
of like is she working for her own needs when
helping Daredevil out and that that's something
I think they could do I don't know how far
they'll go though look at that Countryside
at the end of the episode oh was King wake
it up he I was like I hope not actually
nice oh it does it does move in like those
grungier like the Daredevil movie from the
2000s mes it's moving quick that moves in that
kind of like aggressive dark fastpac it could
have been six episodes and breathed a [Music]
little oh look at that like that that gritty oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa we don't even watch a preview
no we got them all day and date yeah man gosh
coming soon on 5 minutes don't click off this
episode watch the next one thank you to Rocket
money for sponsoring this video a brand that I
am happy to be partnered with thrilled to it's
fortunately one that I have been using for quite
a while now prior to ever green to a partnership
with them I was like that makes for the best kind
of synergy promotion because I can actually talk
about them from my heart here reason being like
many of you guys U like for years I am constantly
downloading all kinds of financial apps that I
keep forgetting to use or I don't really find
quite as beneficial rocket money has been the one
the only one I'm not just saying it is the only
one that I have been able to consistently use
rely on that has been an absolute game Cher for
me on a very personal note running real rejects
is an absolute privilege however you know like I
stress out about taxes and it's the beginning of
the year and I'm like I'm trying to be smarter
and get it all done now I already started like
a a couple months ago getting things in order
managing real reject finances while managing
my own personal finances has been an ongoing
struggle and I'm very big on like efficiency and
being organized but clearly wasn't as good enough
as I uh thought I had so before rocket money came
into my life I was drowning in subscriptions and
struggling to keep track of my expenses and as
I really wanted to like get everything in order
rocket money came at the right time for me I was
overwhelmed with subscriptions I didn't even know
I had or had still been subscribed to I mean
do you ever wonder how many subscriptions you
actually pay for have you ever taken the time to
really do it it could be a little daunting rocket
money helped me see what I was missing and best
part they even canceled those subscriptions for
me with just a simple tap so with rocket
money you can have all your subscriptions
in one place making it easy to cancel anything
unnecessary without the hassle of dealing with
customer service my is so annoying plus they'll
work on getting you refunds and negotiate lower
bills saving you up to 20% you just snap a pick
of your bill and let Rocky money take care of
the rest let me just summarize for you really
quick what they are they're a personal finance
app that fines and cancels unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps lower your bills
with over 5 million users and over $500 million in
cancel subscriptions they've already saved members
an average of $720 a year they help save me a
little bit more than that don't waste your hard
earn money on unused subscriptions cancel them
today at Rocket money.com rejects that's rocket
money.com rejects if you've heard other people
talk about them well use ours Rocky money.com
rejects cuz if you use that promo code rejects
you unlock special benefits and yes using them
is also a great way to support the channel same
time it's just a great way to support your bank
account cuz I cannot stress enough just how much
this app has changed the game for me take control
of your finances with rocket money and enjoy
financial peace of mind uh let's talk about
episode one even though you guys like just watch
episode two there's there's four more now no we
don't roll that way talk this for 40 minutes talk
about 40 more minutes no we can just keep it short
uh right now I mean because it is a bin show I
don't feel it's proper to like I I've adjusted
to the way times have changed that we should
just kind of watch the rest before obviously
before making a final assessment in terms of
a pilot episode I think it was really good
it's a good strong start um I do I am kind of
craving a bit of a change of specific pacing I
understand that we have to get a lot of setup
out of the way uh you know you're also got to
tie it into like yeah how does it connect to
the Hawkeye stuff cuz you were cutting prior to
the Hawkeye events interweaving into the Hawkeye
events and then now we got to go post the Hawkeye
events so you're essentially doing better call
Sol but in one episode and uh so far though I
mean for positives for me I really love uh the
the composition of the shots I think there's a
lot of this really intriguing symmetry they have
with all their angles I think like the big talk of
this will probably be the Daredevil fight be and
I which I actually really respected the handling
of that because they first get you invested
into the action scene before Daredevil ever
shows homeboy could learn to hide a yawn a lot
better John was I don't know what you're talking
about so powerful that was so good what AE I
didn't even open my mouth you can't prove that
I ever did anything with my breath I was just
shocked soad your I'm just shocked by how good
your point was I was like a TI to but if there's
a Tik Tok clip out from this episode it's that
moment that Wasing you cannot mask any worse than
that you know you just open your mouth and I start
fall taking a big old gas watching this show at
are we watching this at like 11: in the morning
what's happening right now never know keep ja up
anyway the segue into the the segue into that was
getting you invested into the action and the
visual like literally a sensory experience and
and and Hawkeye and uh Hawkeye and Echo fighting
first and then Daredevil shows up yes prior to
let's get invested in Daredevil first being here
and and so it was smart for the placement of it
and this like really smart way of how they're
kind of separating itself from the voice of
Hawkeye and then now putting her in the voice of
the Netflix Daredevil shows yeah it's like mainly
there but like those shows were paced better but
granted this is sort of a reintroduction so I'm
waiting to see how this all plays out but loving
the casting and uh so far I I really enjoyed the
first episode uh I think action looks and um
Maya Lopez uh the who's the actress John you
would knowa Cox is her name I would know and John
delivered and yeah I think what I'm waiting for
on there it it's a tall it's a it's a tall order
to ask because you it's all going to be Reliant
primarily on body language and expression to get
really invested into her and I like the choices
of like how they will use uh sound design to kind
of get you into what's going on internally with
her Beyond just speaking sign language and just
Expressions that she has like it's kind of a neat
way to get you into her perspective and her heart
uh which I thought was really smart uh but I I am
still going all right well it is her show still
and I'm going to need to really get invested in
her like her but you know it's still a journey so
so first episode those are my quick three minute
thoughts who wants to go next who wants to go next
oh oh pick me pick me pick me pick me teacher uh I
I like this a lot and I agree with most of what
you said so I'm not going to you know ramble I
have one main concern which is kind of interesting
I'm I'm I'm curious to see how this will play out
across five episodes because in one breath the
pace of this episode I thought they made it work
it moves real fast it's splicing in a bunch of
stuff from the past and it could have felt like
it was edited in a blender and I didn't feel like
that however I feel like when you're in the newer
scenes in the past where you're dealing with her
family and stuff like that the way this episode is
paced made me worry for future episodes basically
not taking much time for that like when they're on
top of the big uh Tower thing and they're looking
down on Bonnie like that was like a scene between
those two characters and you got the sense for you
know their kind of back and forth Rapport and like
that was not the most breathable scene but it was
a breathable scene and I liked that flavor and I
think if you really want to sell us on all the
stuff that they're doing I just hope that they
will take the time appropriately much like the
Daredevil Show on Netflix would have done to yeah
just uh appropriately Revel in these character
beats so that we care that much more but like
I said from here I already cared more about Maya
and her various relationships and her journey thus
far more than in Hawkeye and I like dur Hawkeye
I thought she was a cool addition but it was sort
of like this other thing happening on the side of
that show so yeah like this had all the punch and
all the mood and all the atmosphere and all the
look that you want and now I just hope that it it
breathes a little bit feel like not that it's a
great onetoone comparison but like Z mandan's on
uh he's great on reservation dogs and that show
really lets you live in what this town looks
like it could be which is like you know a strong
populated indigenous sort of area or town not that
this is necessarily on a reservation but you know
like that stuff I feel like that's part of what
you want to steep yourself in when you're getting
to know this person's story and especially with
these teases of you know the birth of the chock
top people and this this fantasy you know I hope
they can proportionately balance all that stuff
out because I like that you have this Prospect of
something Cosmic and something you know mystical
at the beginning which is appropriate for folklore
and that side of things and it doesn't Clash too
hard or contrast too you know dissonantly with
you know the gritty rough and tumble like super
tangible very real kind of style they're going
with so I'm I'm curious to see how they blend
those moving forward but uh strong start by my
metric yeah yeah I like it more than iron fist
season one uh and that's clear that bar that all
right all right Coy now keep in mind we also did
not talk about Kingpin nope we didn't about two so
to me this feels like the Marvel Knights imprint
of comic books which I'm hoping is what they do
with the search light obviously uh I think sorry
Spotlight I think Spotlight is going to be more
Spotlight Spotlight I apologize Spotlight is going
to be more than just dark characters I assume it's
going to be able to highlight other characters and
uh you know it is it is distracting I immediately
felt Greg's tired guys but the spotlight I don't
think is just going to be dark characters but I
do think like Marvel lights Marvel Knights it does
allow you to have an imprint have a different feel
and the feel of Kingpin doesn't quite fully feel
like Netflix to me but it definitely feels closer
to Netflix than Hawkeye and I feel like you have a
really unique opportunity here to have characters
like Ekko like Daredevil like Ghost Rider like
blade you have these characters that belong in
the dark and I would love if they take more
opportunities for things like this my biggest
concern is that it is five episodes it is getting
kind of dropped unceremoniously quickly uh I hope
that with Hulu airing it it will get a little bit
more Prestige because Hulu does have really good
content that is darker I'm hoping an audience
that loves that stuff finds this and it kind of
brings them into the fold and that it gets enough
numbers to show that audiences want this darker
content uh I do think that the Kingpin was able to
retroactively make those scenes in Hawkeye work I
do think that Vincent and arreo is incredible when
he's like this you know the little like cars you
pull back and you wait to launch them I always
feel like Kingpin is the car like right here I
feel like kingpin's always like pois and I think
my issue with Hawkeye was we spent three years
of of like him like this with occasional lashing
out and launching and Hawkeye was just like it was
like a Hot Wheel I don't want a Hot Wheel I want
a poised Viper and I really feel like here we got
the Viper and I want more of that pacing that I do
worry that with a a five episode run it will have
to be so feverish but I really enjoyed this more
than I expected um two Parallels for me that I
didn't expect to jump into my mind I really enjoy
Dominique Thorne in wakanda forever because I love
iron heart and I think she's a good iron heart but
I did feel like that scene some of those scenes at
times felt like they they got added I think they
always intended to use her she did screen test
with Chad Boseman before we lost him but it felt
like they added a couple more scenes in order to
be like we got a series coming I felt similarly
towards the character in Hawkeye where I imagine
she was always going be in it but I think once
they decided to make a spin-off there was more and
I I felt like it was a detriment to both things
Hawkeye felt like it was trying to do too much
and it didn't feel focused and then I also felt
like I didn't connect to her I feel so connected
to her because of how they introduced Daredevil
back in because they made us familiar because
they had their own and scene but I'm afraid unless
they give us some time with just her it will feel
like they're doing too much and then the other
thing it reminded me of is do you remember the
scenes in the Weeden cut that were Snider and it
was like what's happening and then it go back to
then this that that different tone just felt odd I
thought this did a really good job of kind of like
the SN cut keeping its truth and integrity while
incorporating other elements and making you remind
you what you like about the Netflix shows and what
you like about those things so this reminded me of
like okay don't let Hawkeye distract you because
that wasn't my cup of tea I liked parts of it but
it did feel like I was doing too much this feels
like more that streamline I have a vision I have
a tone this felt like directed this felt like
edited felt like it was dpd it felt like a a a
property not like a product and at times Hawkeye
felt like a product so I really enjoyed that this
feels like there's artistic Merit and there's a
lens that someone shooting it through that sees
a vision yeah I would I would definitely no all
puns intended I would 100% Echo that I've have
one wait because sorry I thought you were going to
wrap up the video did you th% what just happened I
thought you were heading the wrap up start making
a point and he just goes I uh I want to you had
that posture of Greg's about to I was I was just
I was transitioning enjoying pool so much dud I'm
just going to go I already forgot my point John
what were you going to say I literally forgot
my point so the vibe literally forgot my point
this early January for days what what are you
going to say no you were going to say something
about Kingpin I said SN SN say what point you
were going to say how does Kingpin know zero sign
language that's one thing thing that I did not get
about this that I feel like would be important
for how important he is to her existence and
their bond and everything he's got this freaking
translator who we've never seen before who I guess
is around just all the time and then none of the
other people are prepared for this high ranking
person in his organization to speak sign language
either no his sign language clearly is not I want
to say I'm I'm glad you interrupted me for this
uh that his sign language is this is my favorite
language is he no in Hawk they have a scene here
when he before he gets shot like when he speaks
he's clearly amateurish at it he only knows a
few words but how has he known her so long he's
been her uncle since she was a child he's never
b a secret Epstein billionaire he's been able
to like heated guy on the flight logs for sure
I I I agree I do age I could also see the flip
where he probably just always had a translator
with it I don't have time to learn this I got
to go kill people and I didn't ever look at my
translator once across all the repeat words I
must have said and have said to me he picked up
seven to nine words we saw that's enough for 20
odd years oh but yeah I I really liked it more
than I expected to be honest yeah yeah it's good
I I really can't remember what I was I it would
come back to I trying for a second I was like
I really can't recall artistic Vision a specific
lens a creative idea from top to bottom SN cut uh
what else I talk about Netflix I I Echo that so
maybe I don't know yeah like it it doesn't feel
like yeah no it doesn't feel like the Disney Plus
shows it actually it actually feels like they let
the filmmakers make film which is pretty cool to
see I saw that breath come up this whole season
I'm just going to watch body language and see how
this I got this go I'm ready to go all righty all
righty guys well I'm done um I'm finished been in
a Daniel de Lewis mood lately moans no and I love
Michael man yeah I have I've been wanting oh you
haven't seen it either no we should do a three-way
reaction uh yeah that's Michael man right dramatic
yeah the three of us should sit for 3 hours and
watch I really I really want to watch watch
Offa watch New Year's Day I watched this like
documentary about like one of those like 40 minute
videos about D le Lewis and and uh like I haven't
seen last of them moans I'm a huge Michael Man
Fan I'm more Michael Man Fan than Daniel de Lewis
I love Daniel de Lewis but I think Michael man's
in my top 10 directors and I think that's the only
film of his I haven't seen I watched Ferrari it
was okay yeah it's spich man though yeah I love
Miami Vice though nobody loves Miami Vice there so
much like space Patrick Williams loves Miami Vice
got to love a good mojito I couldn't even finish
it oh really seen did not like it Char's mustache
is like two mustaches in that movie anyway uh
yeah oh and the other thing too is um ex what
I liked so far about like I don't know you know
what honestly help me out here guys people in the
comments help my uneducated mind who tries to
sound politically correct say the right things
that are respectful uh when it comes to the
Chaka Nation uh being inclusive in here and I
don't know what nation or tribes or like what
the specific race of the actors that they got
involved in this project are uh what I say what I
really respected about it like they start off on
this mystical element which is neat to see however
when you are just in the present day they're not
having all these conversations which I'm sure they
will have when exploring the culture you're just
with the people you're just with the characters
and to me that's usually my favorite kind of
representation is when you just have the actors
and the characters there and then eventually have
some of more of these like conversations you
know and so far right now with that Premiere
episode I thought was a really interesting way to
do it because I don't know what all this mystical
stuff I feel like I don't know if that's going to
be inter dispersed and then build right I think
it maybe it's inspired by like actual culture
stuff but there's a lot of fictional things that
they're probably including in there as opposed to
they are adapting some very specific you know um
Faith or playing with North Norse mythology like
it's a it's an augmented play on a yeah that's
what I imagine they're doing I but I don't know I
really I really don't know I have no knowledge so
uh maybe is this real mythology is this the real
creation myth yeah uh it's this real like choon
Nation um the faith folklore and faith folklor is
the word I'm looking for spirituality all righty
guys well um uh I don't know if I ever found that
point but I'm happy to be here anyway it doesn't
matter we're at the end of the video all right
well thanks for being here and uh let's watch
episode two episode two let's do it guo Galindo
welcome to your second month of shout outs here
for real rejects now it's 2024 start of a new
year I'm going to Fathom what your New Year's
resolution is oh and your New Year's resolution
this year is to clip your nails a little more
often I know you you're Italian those things get
really long and disgusting and full of spaghetti
sauce I understand how it goes man that's a [__]
the ball plumbing and you're it gets icky and you
don't wash your hands and then your nails get
all dirt dirty and you're like ah forget about
it then you give a backand to your spouse I get
it man I know how it goes somebody some concrete
shoes get it all over your hands yeah you know
and then you have them swim with the fishes ah
forget about it so uh guo Galindo man I hope that
you know cleaning your fingernails it's a great
way to make sure you're not leaving you know uh
evidence behind and also you won't pick up any
blood residue from all the dead bodies that you're
hauling around and digging up shovel for I get how
it goes let's just make sure my racist shout out
is accurate gindo is name origin hold on a second
Spanish oh my bad oh no okay well then I hope
you're colonizing um yes I hope you're sending
some conquistadors our way when you're colonizing
my friend um you know you can get a lot of dirt in
your hands when you're taking over land that's
true and blood and all sorts of other things
making sure you can make sure you can effectively
take the things that are are mandated as yours
that you truly right fully deserve yeah yeah we
got this [__] under control so G I hope this has
encouraged you to stick through for the remainder
of the year because clearly we care about TLC and
customization when shouting people loud happy
New Year clip your nails they look [Music] gross